between mountain stages the big  difference would be a stage where  you have a long flat section and then a  climb in the final as opposed to a stage  where you have climbs all day  i think for me it's very much like beta  fuel  and normal gels when you're climbing a  lot and  also descending because it's tricky  often to  to get food in when we're inevitably  climbing at a pretty high  pace almost all stage we want to be able  to just  trickle feed it and just stay on top of  it when you have a long flat section  then i  typically tend to transition to a little  bit more solid foods like  bakes or rice cakes with descents the  main thing is  staying safe and holding your position  so just being able to grab something  easily or a bottle is what you want  really